hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk and
this is another episode of
overrated underrated with me garyvee
overrated or underrated what does gary
think
let's get into the show
um okay i'm gonna do something i am
gonna do something you can keep that
whole thing maybe we'll black it out
like
let's do a little ode there to to ask
her yeah i just want to give a shout out
to
drock good to see you uh this is a very
special episode of overrated underrated
this is the sports card edition one
thing with the explosion of this show
is i think i'm gonna use it to answer
the questions that i get bombarded with
on text 212-931-5731
on dm on social i see it all
but i'm busy i'm working all the time
i'm doing my personal life stuff so like
it's hard to like
answer them all i'm gonna use overrated
underrated occasionally as a catch-all
this is the sports card edition psa
psa uh underrated
uh it is the establishment as you know
drock and others i love sgc
i think there's a space for bgs i think
there's
some other emerging players i do think
long term maybe there's a computer that
comes along and takes the humans out of
it
but the group that just bought psa
is some professional ass [ __ ]
and i expect big things from them and
i'm a big fan as you know
i'm betting on the the jockey over the
horse if you go back to that jack welsh
post maybe we'll pop that up right here
that i posted on instagram the other day
when we talked about bezos jeff bezos
big ball
love them big hairy balls oh god
in 2015 we just both loved them because
we were betting on the jockey
it continued to play out i believe in
the jockeys that now run psa for
everybody's watching this psa is the
grading company
that we can throw an image here and
circle it that is like the grade cards
on a ten point scale this is like the
most respected grading company
uh the leader in the space and so i
think it's underrated because i think
there's new leadership
that will make it stronger and i'm
excited to see what happens
alternative rookies alternative rookies
are grossly grossly grossly underrated
let's do some editing in this one
i'm obsessed with the nike and interlake
jordan i'm obsessed
with uh the messy sticker i'm obsessed
with um
jesus i'm trying to think of like
there's a weird stockton rookie card
from europe that's a year before his
rookie there's a
there's a a doughnut version of um
of a pip and rookie card from 87 not 88
there's the barkley jms from 85 not 86
when there's a there's the hank aaron
rookie card the cookies there's
there's these alternative rookie cards
that there's a pat riley jack in the box
you know these weird companies i view
them as contemporary art
i think what you're living through now
with sports cards is the pablo is like
kind of like the the old-school european
art the jordans the mona lisa [ __ ] the
jordans
the mantles but i think as this industry
explodes
people are going to look at supply and
demand and if you look at the supply of
these weird rookie cards there's so much
less
than the established tops and clear
version so all it needs is demand
and as people get bored and as people
get creative
and as other dynamics happen as other
people get excited about things
this always happens in every sector i
think alternative rookie cards
are some of the biggest money makers and
cards stickers
stickers it's funny i just mentioned
them like i'm a big fan of
the sticker culture in europe it's very
simple stickers
panini stickers and others but mainly
panini stickers
european soccer cards are actually
stickers right
and so to me as
soccer proper football gets bigger in
the us the predominantly market
you see it with the mambape sticker
right you see it with other stickers
maradona zz you know you see with other
stickers they're exploding
so i think stickers in general
interesting specifically for me mba
stickers
because the look of zion all that stuff
the stickers
pretty rare hard to grade much tinier
marketplace than the cards
i think stickers in general continue to
get bigger
be because and i'm not talking 86 87
flair jordan stickers which were
stickers and cards
i mean actually stickers stand alone
stickers i like that whole space
quite a bit because i think european
proper football
culture continues to matter those are
stickers
and so i think stickers are sneaky
underrated underrated
luca bass prism psi 10.
[Music]
lucca-based prism psa 10. um what's the
population on that
26 214 15
375 css
one more time how many psa tens 15 000
15 000
what i'm asking for is the population
how many are there perfectly graded by
the top company psa
15 000 so i think about supply and
demand the pro
this one's a very hard one for me
similar to just rating zion
in the last episode the human not the
card i think lucas so good
and will fall into that top 20 players
of all time category if he doesn't get
hurt
derrick rose right that i'm scared to
say overrated but i'm scared about the
population
because there's 15 000 plus of these
there's still a ton in wax
took about 25 000 probably in
circulation that takes a lot of demand
there's also a ton of other luca cards
including the super premiums that we
didn't have for barclay hakeem
viewing other top 50 players where
there's only the fleet of rookie
in the next three years it could be
underrated but i'm going to go with
oh god i'm going to go with properly
rated because
even though long long term i think it
can be overrated he just might end up
being so good
that 25 000's not enough against the
supply against the demand 2018 panini
prison
the mumbai prism rookie i think that's
grossly overrated
i think soccer grossly overrated i think
soccer stickers
is the culture and will be the culture
and i think that's the rookie card
the mumbai first prism what's the
population on that but 2
309 psyche yeah um
i'm not as high on that a lot of people
people are obsessed with prism in
general
i'm a little less obsessed with prism
it's incredible product i'm about it but
i'm gonna go with overrated even though
i think mumbai is an incredible talent
as a soccer football player
cards marvel cards are underrated i
think
comic book cards is something i'm
starting to try to
by the way i want to give to how many i
have of these cards i think that'd be
good transparency so start one more time
psa nuts
luca bass i think i have 183 of those
but if you remember throw back the
throwback video this card was 35
when i started buying it a year ago that
luca rookie's now 75
i bought i was telling everybody on
social media only 30 days ago to buy
them they were 40.
it is now over 400 tick tock
sports cards are coming get educated
get cash i bought almost all of them for
under seventy dollars a piece as a
matter of fact
i've never paid over seventy dollars for
deluca so throw back a little video
there so i have about 185 of those
um what was the next card but i have
none but i have like 10 or 15
stickers but you know a lot of this is
gonna be i'm buying the way i believe
marvel kind marvel cards i have like
i have like six random weird things i
bought which were like stickers from the
70s none of the modern 90 91
stuff uh protected it but i think it's
underrated and i think i'm about to
start doing some real investigation
because i think you know listen like
i've said that charizard can't
tears acl the hulk batman superman
there's some 1940 superman cards i'm
starting to look at
i think in general dc and marvel comic
book cards
can have a moment underrated 2001 upper
deck tiger woods
2001 upper deck tiger woods i have 100
bgs 9.5
just trying to get my transparency i
think you know you're catching me right
in between the we i'm sure we'll
probably post this next week which means
the documentary on hbo is done because
the second part comes out this sunday
um and we'll probably put this out on
tuesday so it just ended
i think there was a because of the last
dance documentary
everybody wants to buy cards before
documentaries last dance was a
phenomenon
i think super long term that car what's
the pop
population on that 21 323
yeah i think it's overrated i'm gonna go
with overrated
i think especially right now i think
super long term it can work out i do
think the sports illustrated
version and the sp authentic versions
are gonna be the ones for tiger
it's tiger if he gets weirdly hot again
and wins a couple more majors but i'm
gonna go with overrated
all right tyler hero prism rookie uh
ps uh psa 10. the 1010 is
28 2 830. so a couple things i think
tyler
hero is super fun i think he's swaggy as
[ __ ] i think he's a real good ball
player
i'm going to go with aggressively
aggressively aggressively overrated and
i'm going to use this opportunity to
make a bigger point
i think the biggest vulnerability in
sports cards right now is
rookie chasing for people that want to
sit on it a little bit longer
than within three and six and nine and
12 week windows
ray allen kevin garnett allen iverson
tracy mcgrady um i can go on and tim
duncan who's a top [ __ ] 12 player of
all time
um john stockton reggie miller
like if you look at the data around how
much
how much is a hero 230 bucks or
something like that
right now because people are day trading
buying and flipping buying and flipping
by and flipping these young players
lamella ball's going to go through so i
think he's a baller like it's going to
be this thing
i also hate that year is that that's
last year right
yeah panini made a drillion of them it's
the same reason morant
and zion i i don't like the whole thing
i don't like the rookie spec thing at
all
that's going on for this reason
90 of the people that are being bought
right now this last
four years somebody's gonna get held
with the bag like jason tatum
is a baller is he gonna be one of 25
greatest players of all time
because if he's not then his rookie card
in 12 years is gonna be a real [ __ ]
problem
aka somebody's gonna pay a lot more
today then it's gonna be worth a lot
less than 12 years
if he wins a championship next year and
as the guy
and you buy it today and you sell it
that night you're gonna make money
donovan mitchell tatum like
jaylen brown like there's so many great
young players right
trey young like they're loaded there's
so much talent
the problem is look at barkley and
malone and ewing and elijah one and
duncan
and like shaq look at shaquille [ __ ]
o'neal
culturally and actual player he was
also a rookie during high production
years
and his cards are not expected tell her
your rookie cards are more than shaq
[ __ ] rookie cards
in the same production and even i i i'm
going up to my head i bet you
look at the pops on certain shack psa
tens like the tops
regular and the [ __ ] stadium club and
the upper deck versus tyler hero prisms
tyler here is more expensive and there's
still a ton of tyler hero in whacks
tyler here's not gonna end up being a
better all-time player than shaquille
o'neal i'm ready to put that down right
now
i think people are gonna get crushed
when the momentum goes the other way i
think day trading day to day
and you know what's going on sports you
know who's hurt who's got an opportunity
that's fun but i
hate the long-term nature of the
majority of the rookie speculating
across the board
of course there'll be four to five guys
that become kobe's lebrons
two or three guys that become kobe
lebron shacks tim duncan's
you have to really hit it you gotta
really get like trout or lebron
otherwise
you know look at how inexpensive dwyane
wade and carmelo anthony are
most of these almost 98 of these rookies
will not be better than carmelo anthony
all time on top
500 list
[Music]
2003 and top corona lebron james grossly
underrated i have 53 of them
um i didn't pay over 1100 for any of
them
either 20 000 now um
it's gonna be a hundred thousand dollar
card one day lebron james and michael
jordan
[Music]
how many are there two thousand four
hundred or something like that twenty
one thousand
one overall psa tens i mean three
seven no no that's shorter than
eighty-six i'm talking about lebron
i'm sorry okay two thousand wow i'm on
my [ __ ]
wow two thousand eighty-three well
that's 63.
right so to me i know 2063
people that are going to want a lebron
perfect
psa 10 chrome rookie over the next
decade
people i've got 53 of them other people
got like like
that card's going to the moon michael
jordan here in 10 19
i hate michael jordan more than anybody
i own two i think i might have three
um uh which is the biggest mistake i've
made in three years i've been in because
i've been yelling you watch videos three
years ago i [ __ ] this up
um i paid 30k for mine um
there's 317 of them it's 230 000
i'd be stunned if it's not a million
dollars
the most underrated card it is the mona
lisa modder
it is um a big regret i have for not
having more
golf carts golf carts are
underrated you know because outside of
tiger i don't even know what a phil
mickelson rookie looks like in my eyes
or
johnson spieth or whoever is like
rocking there
so i'm gonna go with slightly underrated
i think all cards garbage pail kids
batman
the a team golf you know i think
all of it right at this second
underrated in a three year window
grossly underrated i think the bumblebee
uh dwayne rock johnson i think i own two
of those um
psa 10 which i think there's 30 of which
is like now 14 000 i think it's
massively underpriced talk about a six
figure card these guys are in culture
they're also
hulk hogan and andre giant are much more
the hulk and batman than they are hank
aaron
and roberto clemente i think wrestling
cards great community in wrestling
if wrestling has like 16 to 25 people in
the wrestling community get hardcore
about cards
that's a big ecosystem of die hards that
i think come in hard
i think wrestling is actually very
underpriced 2019 panini prison
zion williamson grossly grossly
overpriced what's the production
uh overrated 26926 14
673 massively
i'm more confident that luke is a top 15
player than zion at the second
it's just too much inventory like these
guys
have to go on to become one of the 15
best players of all time
to make these numbers work i think the
zion's like seven eight hundred bucks
it's been a thousand like
i don't see it garnett like is i'm gonna
be better than garnett all time
i think so but like i'm not confident
i just think there's way too much risk
there's so many places to spend seven
hundred dollars better
today so many places you know we've
talked about i think
one of the underrated places is that 90s
era that you know
garnett ray allen iverson man of genova
there's there's some cheap good deals
there compared to these youngsters who i
love
great kids but [ __ ] 2003
mega kraken's pretty inaudible
there's so few of these ronaldo and
messy cards let's do a lot of imaging
post them so everybody can see us
how much is it you know i don't know
there's so few right you don't know the
population
there's 38 psa yeah i mean
under under underrated he's one of 10
best proper football players of all time
he's culturally relevant soccer cards
are gonna continue to go up
it's a good chunk below messi if i
recall haven't looked recently but
i'm gonna go underpriced 2013 top
bloodline conor mcgregor auto
underpriced i think ufc cards are under
price i've bought two of those ufc
connors
recently um and i think ufc cards are
underpriced
ufc's mma is a huge sport for a long
time like i think people haven't gotten
there yet
i think ufc is a place to go there's
only 36 population 27. it's a really
interesting card 2018
top update juan soto
[Music]
i think properly priced i think there's
a ton of inventory there as well
i think it's cheap though compared to
the basketball stuff
and i think soto could be the best
player
he could be one of the 17 best players
of all time he's young derrick rose
again
but i'm gonna go with underpriced i like
that card a lot i like soda a lot i have
25 of those i think at this point maybe
more i don't know maybe 75.
luka's mother i think that's an
underrated story
this is like a rumor that goes around
that lucas mom signed his cards his
rookie year not him
i don't i i really haven't done i don't
get excited about conspiracy theories so
i don't have really a lot of info but
it's an underrated story
kaboom inserts kaboom inserts are
underrated
this has been the biggest thing that my
brother aj has invested in i think 85
of aj's behavior is kaboom i've got
probably a mix of like
35 40 kabooms mainly basketball 2013.
um i do have a bunch of sam darnold
kabooms
so i've got a lot riding on sammy um but
probably like 40 or 50 overall kaboom is
an insert that's extremely rare
they've got the comic book element
they've got the supply and demand
element they've got the heat on the
street
like kaboom's like you know what kaboom
is i can see like michael b jordan the
actor being like i'm gonna get into this
be like oh these kabooms are fresh right
like
i can see like the baby being like all
right garyvee like
and i'll be like here's what you should
buy jordan he's like [ __ ] i'm gonna
get these kabooms they're [ __ ] fresh
they're like they're icy
um they're the one the kaboom insert to
me is the one i think they're grossly
underpriced i think with the comic book
and the and how rare they are as people
get educated about kaboom i think that's
the one
uh 2017 prism patrick mahomes
i own none of those regrettably what's
what's the population
of the psa 10 849 yeah i think it's
under price i think patrick mahomes
bar ring injury um becomes one of the
best quarterbacks if not
top three quarterbacks of all time um
i'm pretty sad i don't have any of those
1979
opt opg grossly under price
i mean are we saying the psa 10 yeah i
mean aren't there three of them or two
yeah i mean somebody just paid over a
million for it if
in 10 years if that's a 10 million card
that would make sense to me
i think it's grossly underpriced he's
the greatest hockey player of all time
super rare there's only two in the world
you get into mona lisa [ __ ] underpriced
card
funds card funds are underrated i don't
think people realize how many people are
circling around
raising 5 10 15 million dollars they're
going to lead to 10 million dollar wing
rescue gonna lead to kabooms being
10x lead to jordan being a million i
think card funds
real capital wall street life you know
i'm not involved in any i have i don't
know any real detail but i know i get
emailed all the time like
i am stanley thompson from merrill lynch
we are putting together a 10 million
dollar fine to buy sports cards would
you like
and i'm trying to stay very omni so i'm
trying to be transparent with my
what my holdings are my opinions here
but if you look at all my videos i think
i've been ridiculously historically
correct
um and uh and i feel like card funds are
underrated i don't think people
understand the financial impact
of 400 million dollars coming into the
market trying to get the top 10 percent
of stuff
the bubble the bubble is underrated in
the reverse
this is why everything is in detail
right like i think i think like
at any moment you know pokemon can come
out uh video games can come out like
things change something might capture
the attention of all these people
comic books rated video games like you
know you got to always pay attention
that you should always be worried you're
in a bug bowl
which means you don't mortgage the house
you're smart you're thoughtful you do
things that you like
things you can afford every card i own i
make pretend i go to zero
and i think people have to do that don't
underestimate the bubble
because that [ __ ] will pop on your face
1961
we're oscar robin robertson
did john morganson have anything to do
with this list
i love it um i own probably about nine
or ten of these maybe 12
under 20 for sure um
[Music]
listen i think vintage is a 61 player
basketball
70 tops basketball 72 tops basketball
the jordan magic bird i think vintage
basketball is wildly underpriced with a
three-year broken record on this
so i'm gonna go in general are we saying
which psa or is it just that card
one ps810 yeah i mean that's stupid it's
100
yeah it's i think the top 20 the top 50
players in the nba
in history are collectively underpriced
and oscar 61 is one of those cards
that's you know the 48 mike and
those cards are just going to keep
everyone's like oh my doctor jay hasn't
gotten as much
as this thing i'm like sure but like
2003 tops chrome duane ray
how many are those psa tens over there
uh 654.
do you know how much it is right now no
cool
i think dwyane wade's underpriced
because of what i think he's up to post
career
i think he's a top 100 player and i
think he's
culturally relevant if dwyane wade ended
up being president of the united states
of america that would not surprise me
based on his humanity his
amazingness as a human oh by the way i
own probably four or five of these um
uh his culture he's just a leader
him and his wife his family i just i
think he's underpriced so i'm gonna go
with underrated
ebay under under underrated it's the
[ __ ] most important platform and
stockx is doing a nice job people are
selling direct discords
but like ebay is the [ __ ] industry
it's the data
sports card values in 2026.
sports card value in 2026 underrated
in the super premium low pop vintage or
three four best players the trouts
and the lebrons of their generation
[Music]
uh overrated on a lot of this thing that
i'm trying to explain to people
[Music]
there's a lot of speculating going on
some kid can have one good night and
people are like bye i think people are
gonna get burned this is exactly what
happened 92 to 94.
get thoughtful unless you're day trading
then that's different
buy a kid gets hot for a week davonte
graham you can make money i get it
that's the show hope you learned
something see ya there's 2830 tyler hero
psa tens there's an
unbelievable amount of packs still in
the world so we're probably another 4x
so we'll get to 10
000. but let's even say it's at this
number 2800.
there's 1944 shaquille o'neals
right so there's right so right so
there's a
good chunk lex 2800 you said there yeah
28
30. right so there's like a 25 percent
less shacks
and shack is 380 dollars
tyler here is 230 and like when you take
in the vig like
that makes no sense that's the problem
there's 315 shack upper deck
excuse me stadium upper deck bases and
there's only 315 of them and it's 2 600
bucks
like
shaq is either stupid stupid stupid
underpriced
or tyler hero luca tre like all these
guys are just
wildly overpriced ja jaron jackson
like that's the problem supply and
demand
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon